- I mentioned your Grammy nomination
so congratulations.
You were just nominated again.
(audience cheering)
That's so cool.
You shot the music video
"I'm Good" on a boat.
Was that fun?
Do you like being on a boat?
I get sick on a boat.
- Oh man.
It was like, it looked like very grand.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- The boat looked really
grand on the music video.
It looked, you know,
but it was an old boat
and like the hydraulics
or I don't know what the
proper terminology is.
- Oh, so you were rocking.
- So it was like so bumpy
and we were just like holding on.
I have literally pictures
of everybody in my,
oh, there I go, yeah.
- This is not what I look like on a boat.
I'm yaking off the side.
- Oh gosh.
- Yeah
- Yeah, everybody was like
throwing up and it was crazy.
- Oh really?
- Oh yeah.
I was so close to throwing up
but I was holding myself.
I was like if I, because you know
when you shoot a music video,
you're shooting the whole day.
You know how it goes.
- Yeah, yeah.
- So I was like, if I throw up now
I am going to be wait,
there's people on the wall.
- Yeah.
(audience laughing)
So we have people from all over.
Yeah.
During COVID, the whole audience
was actually screens like this
and they could tune in from all over
and we thought it was kind of cool.
So we kept some of it.
- That's so cool.
- Yeah, yeah.
They're not vomiting, which is
even better right now, yeah.
- You can tell I have
ADD 'cause I'm just like.
- I am 100% the same way.
So I totally.
- Sorry.
- I went with you, squirrel.